pense pas
j'ai 14 ans c'est la première fois que
je rentre dans un restaurant étoilé
il ya des dorures au plafond des nappes
blanches des serveurs qui retire avec un
tamis parfait les cloches sur les plats
des plats avec un dressage méticuleux et
chirurgical c'est un monde de rêve de
perfection de luxe même ça a été un coup
de foudre
je me suis dit c'est ça que je veux
faire je cuisinais tout le temps quand
je rentrais être court la simple pause
goûter se transformer en deux heures de
cuisine minimum jean foot est partout
mon père ray j'absorbais tout je
connaissais guide michelin parker je
réalise et même des dîners chez avec mes
voisins où je leur demandais que les
plats aussi que j'avais réalisé pourrait
se trouver dans un restaurant est trop
long c'était une obsession
certains rêvent nba première ligue
bah moi je rêvais robuchon ducasse passe
à wannsee pis j'avais littéralement la
tête dans les étoiles
alors mes parents ont essayé de me
dissuader un peu disant que c'était un
métier de chien que j'allais travailler
des heures pour pas grand chose
avec le recul isr j'avais un peu raison
je disais en plus soutenus par le
professeur qui disait que j'étais
destiné à longueuil les études a fait
une école de commerce ou fait une école
hôtelière ça c'est la classe
d'accord on veut on peut moi j'ai pas pu
déjà parce que les tarifs d école
hôtelière suisse ont vite calmé mes
parents et ils se sont vite rendu compte
que mes cours de philo ou des sms était
beaucoup plus remplie d'idées de plats
aux croquis que de cours passe ton bac
d'abord c'est ce qu'ils m'ont dit bah je
les ai eus miraculeusement avec mention
et puis ils ont accepté donc j'allais
faire à 18 ans encore puceau l'école de
gastronomie française ferrandi je
n'avais aucune idée de ce qui était le
vrai travail j'étais un gosse
j'ai promis à mon père que j'allais
devenir le plus jeune chef étoilé de
france bon spoiler alert je n'ai pas été
et j'ai quand même mis toutes les
chances de mon côté donc j'ai ouvert le
guide rouge
j'ai cherché le restaurant étoilé plus
proche de chez moi puis-je aller toquer
à la porte
là dessus il ya un immense monsieur qui
me qui m'ouvre la porte c'était le chef
de cuisine judy jouait de son apprenti
et il accepte
j'allais devenir l'apprenti d'un
restaurant étoilé
j'étais hyper fier il avait même écrit
sur mon gâteau d'anniversaire en route
vers l'excellence
j'allais travailler 80 heures par
semaine
sept jours sur sept je m'en foutais
j'allais enfin cuisiner que du plaisir
dans s'est pas passé comme prévu
je crois qu'il ya pas un soir où je suis
pas rentré en pleurs j'étais un bizuth
la pression psychologique elle était
terrible j'ai subi humiliations
moqueries dénigrement en fait l'ambition
du chef de cuisine à l'époque c'était de
me détruire pour me construire comme lui
le souhaitez et je vous rassure mon cas
il n'est pas isolé
des milliers de cuisiniers pourront vous
raconter leurs déboires d'apprentissage
parfois avec des violences physiques
j'y allais chaque matin avec la boule au
ventre me disant qu'est ce qui me
réserve aujourd'hui
en fait je peux si vous avez lu
ratatouille mini ghouini c'était moi et
mes parents me regarder en dix ans mais
dit qu'on arrête tout je regardais je me
regardais dans le miroir j'avais perdu 6
kg j'avais des cernes jusqu'aux pieds je
regardais mes mains brûlées par la cites
parce que quand on est en haut fourneau
généralement utilisés l'acide et je me
demandais mais pourquoi pourquoi je
m'inflige ça mon job c'est de faire
plaisir aux gens
alors pourquoi moi je souffre j'en chie
comme ça le métier de cuisinier c'est un
immense paradoxe pour l'émotion
passagère que peut procurer un joli plat
derrière il ya des centaines des
milliers d'heures de doute de sueur de
larmes
dans mon job le plaisir du client il est
lié à une montagne de déplaisir non je
vais vous poser une question quand on va
dans un restaurant
qu'est ce qu'on recherche un moment de
bonheur
il ya un client qui a une foi dit à guy
savoy
vous avez rendu l'éphémère inoubliable
c'est ça la force de notre métier c'est
qu'on crée des souvenirs et ses
souvenirs
ils se doivent d'être inoubliable sinon
ils se perdent dans un océan de moments
comme on est à tous des milliers dans
notre vie sinon ils deviennent banales
et c'est peut-être ça qui nous fait plus
peur en tant que cuisinier c'est de
devenir banal que notre prestation que
nos plats s'en foutent bon il ya la
rentabilité aussi qui nous empêche de
dormir quand l'instant mais non ça c'est
une autre histoire
la pression du coup de feu elle nous
transcende
mais nous détruit aussi physiquement et
mentalement il ya un parallèle que
j'aime bien faire c'est celui de la boxe
je fais de la boxe depuis cinq ans et en
boxe on prend des coups mais le pire en
fait c'est qu'on aime ça et bien apparu
que la cuisine c'est la même chose on
aime notre métier autant qu'on le
déteste il ya une deuxième chose qui
s'est passé aussi pendant ces années
c'est que j'ai développé une certaine
haine de des cuisiniers avec lesquels je
travaillais mais je vais appeler ça un
peu le syndrome de stockholm culinaire
les gens qu'on déteste n'arrive pas
vraiment à les détester
on les admire il ya un profond talent il
ya un profond il ya un profond respect
qui est dû à leur talent alors leur
engouement leur passion leur dévouement
pour leurs clients et les lots restants
et c'est pour ça un peu que c'est un
métier de fou c'est parce que c'est un
peu maso on explose un peu tout les
usages de produits
ce soit drogue alcool klopp ont
pulvérisé moyenne d' usage quotidien
nationalement j'ai tenu comme ça pendant
cinq ans j'ai frôlé une petite
dépression à l'âge de 20 ans j'ai tant
un stage
un deux étoiles michelin finalement la
cuisine que j'aimais tant j'avais envie
de lavaux mire puis venus l'un des
passages un peu les plus importants de
ma jeune existence
j'ai voulu changer d'ère je suis parti
en australie et je revenu et j'ai
intégré un restaurant étoilé qui a été
l'un des premiers sur paris à utiliser
les produits de la fourche à la
fourchette
alors la fourche à la fourchette qu'est
ce que c'est je vous la faire simple en
gros l'agriculteur envoie ses produits
le mardi matin le mardi midi ils sont
dans l'assiette du client et il n'y a
pas d'intermédiaire
ça c'est révolutionnaire et pour la
première fois j'ai compris que cuisiner
écologie doivent rimer ensemble j'ai
travaillé pendant neuf mois g c'était
très dur encore une fois avec un sous
chef qui dépasse un peu les bornes et
j'ai eu un drame familial et ce drame
familial cette fois ci ça a été un peu
le switch
j'ai décidé de dire merde d'arrêter la
cuisine terminer là dessus au même
moment j'ai le chef de cuisine que je
respecte énormément qui vient me voir
qui me dit écoute on a d'autres projets
pour toi tu dois rester ces projets
c'était l'ouverture de 36 établissements
restaurants ou commerces de bouche avec
un sourcing hyper pointu et là je me
suis dit c'est un projet fou je suis un
peu engagés je veux en faire partie
donc j'ai vite retourné ma veste et
comme tout projet utopique c'est un peu
la roulette russe
il ya une chance sur deux que ça passe
pas et qu'on perde tout c'est ce qui
s'est passé la direction a accumulé 5
millions 5 millions d'euros de dette
g j'ai reçu des chèques en bois et j'ai
décidé d'attaquer en justice
je voulais pas me laisser faire au bout
d'un an j'ai gagné et je me suis posé la
question mais humainement j'ai gagné
quoi j'avais rien gagné j'avais joué
j'avais perdu donc là encore je
m'interroge je me dis mais qu'est ce que
je fais j'arrête la cuisine
j'essaie de construire quelque chose de
nouveau ou je fais preuve d'abnégation
et je continue là dedans
au même moment j'ai mon meilleur ami qui
fait un burn-out je reconnais plus on
s'est posés on s'est demandé ce qu'on
allait faire
on a décidé de faire un tour du monde
mais on voulait que ce tour du monde il
soit utile il et apporte quelque chose
on a décidé de faire un documentaire sur
la souveraineté alimentaire d'aller
rencontrer pendant dix mois dans 15 pays
les acteurs du changement lié à
l'alimentation et serrant contre elle
ont redonné un sens à ma vie
ce que j'ai compris que cuisine et
écologie ne doivent pas rimer ensemble
ne doivent faire qu'un alors vous allez
me demander qu'est ce que la
souveraineté alimentaire et pourquoi ce
sujet je vais essayer de vous la résumer
assez simplement en étant un peu
alarmiste
825 millions personnes souffrent de faim
dans le monde
un milliard de personnes souhaitant
perdre son dansethon surpoids 25 % des
gaz à effet serre sont issus de
l'agriculture
un tiers des ressources produites par
directement à la poubelle
deux milliards de personnes à nourrir en
plus d'ici 2050 une planète bleue en
surchauffe
comment nourrir durablement l'humanité
ce que je vous garantis que si on n'a
plus rien à bouffer clairement tous nos
au dessus s'ils seront secondaires notre
petit cuisinier il a changé maintenant
enfin pendant des années on a on appris
à la nature on a on a importé on a
consommé sans avoir vraiment aucune idée
de l'impact que cela pourrait avoir à
long terme
on a on a pris sans vraiment se poser
les questions
au-delà du fait de faire plaisir aux
gens maintenant on se doit de prendre en
compte un certain nombre de facteurs et
ces facteurs c'est les suivants on doit
prendre en compte le bilan carbone de
chacun de nos ingrédients on va prendre
en compte le bien-être animal si on
décide de faire de la viande ou pas on
doit prendre en compte le mode de pêche
utilisées si les responsables des
écosystèmes marins en ont on doit
prendre en compte le mode de maraîchage
utiliser sa rémunération
on doit expliquer à ses clients qu'une
tomate c'est de juin à septembre qu'il
est pas normal qui écrit pays-bas alors
qu'on sait en faire ici en france on
doit expliquer à ses clients on va
monter juste 100 au bon prix un pour
cent de la population française n'aurait
les 99 autres et que au passage on a 1
suscite tous les deux jours dans le
monde paysan et enfin aussi on doit
expliquer aussi la fragilité de notre
système
je suis parisien dopé en ile de france
ces quatre jours d'autosuffisance
alimentaire
puisqu'on est en gironde à bordeaux ces
16 jours d'autosuffisance alimentaire
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut encore
continuer longtemps comme ça moi je suis
pas sûr pourtant on a toutes les
solutions à quoi aqua pony agroécologie
permaculture alors pourquoi on change
pas au delà du plaisir de bien manger du
plaisir culinaire
maintenant il ya une réelle
responsabilité qui incombe aux clients
manger c'est devenu un acte militant
manger c'est cautionner un système où en
défendre un autre les plaisirs et les
des plaisirs pour moi c'est la métaphore
parfaite du métier de cuisinier
mais qu'en est il de la vie concernant
la mienne voilà ce que je me dis si
j'avais pas reçu de chèques en bois
est-ce que j'aurais pu partir au tour du
monde si je l'avais pas fait ce tour du
monde
ce que j'aurais pu faire top chef sans
ce tour du monde
est ce que j'aurai les mêmes convictions
écologiques est-ce que je penserais que
notre façon de manger de consommer peut
devenir un frein au réchauffement
climatique et possiblement changer le
monde et enfin si j'avais pas ils
étaient humiliés des graines fort moqué
pendant des années en cuisine ce que
j'aurai la même niaque qui m'auraient
permis d'accéder à la finale de
l'émission
au final c'est bien les des plaisirs qui
ont tracé les chemins de ma vie la même
façon qu après l'orage l'arc en ciel les
des plaisirs sont pour moi l'un des
passages obligatoires pour accéder au
bonheur
on doit manger un sandwich triangle sur
une aire d'autoroute pour profiter reste
pour apprécier un restaurant de qualité
on doit rater une recette s'obstiner
pour une fille née en apprécier le
succès on a accepté la mort pour
profiter du vivant on va se battre
contre la maladie pour voir son fils
qu'user pour joël robuchon
on doit
on doit se faire maltraiter dans en
cuisine pour se dire qu'un jour quand on
ouvrira sans restaurant jamais
entraînera les gens de la sorte et on
doit se tromper de mode de production
déry culture pour in fine et si on veut
changer arriver à une production
vertueuse alors maintenant sûr je vais
conclure sur une petite note d'optimisme
on va parler de votre futur mais pour
regarder votre futur il va falloir
regarder votre passé quand vous avez eu
un moment difficile dans votre vie vous
avez envie de dire merde de tout lâcher
et vous avez tenu qu'est ce qui s'est
passé derrière qu'est ce que vous avez
lu un orage ou à l'arc en ciel
merci